نعلن اليوم عن اتهامات في
المقاطعات الوسطى والجنوبية من
كاليفورنيا ضد اثنين من أفراد الخدمة الفعلية
في البحرية الأمريكية
[موسيقى]
تزعم لائحة الاتهام لدينا أنه على
مدار أكثر من عام وفي
مناسبات متعددة، تم إرسال
معلومات الدفاع الوطني إلى الصين بما في ذلك
وثائق صور مقاطع فيديو وكتيبات تقنية
لتبادل دفع ضابط مخابرات له
آلاف الدولارات
[موسيقى] [
موسيقى] [
موسيقى]
[موسيقى]
تثبت التهم تصميم جمهورية الصين الشعبية
على الحصول على معلومات
مهمة لدفاعنا الوطني بأي
وسيلة
حتى تتمكن من ذلك  أن يُستخدم لصالحهم، فإن
السلوك المزعوم يمثل أيضًا
انتهاكًا للالتزام الرسمي
لأفراد جيشنا بالدفاع عن بلدنا لحماية
أسرارنا وحماية زملائهم من
أعضاء الخدمة.